okay I should be live
last time I streamed was yesterday
actually last night I was in in Prague
and now I'm in London and the weather
here is a bit suspicious was raining
earlier and now there's random like
bursts of lightning and thunder but I'm
gonna try and survive for the next few
hours I don't know how long I'm going to
stream hello Braden hello Nathan hello
Jennifer - hello Ariel good to see you
all
I've also been troubleshooting with the
stream just because there's been lag and
even now ok maybe not now but there's
going to be like a good deal of lag so I
won't play too much like bullet or Blitz
but I'll try and do just fewer
challenges let's start with a tactic and
I'll wait for the challenges to come see
three cuz it's just simple hey Nathan
with the host thanks Nathan
I wonder if we can just take and then
play eh
maybe this rookie eight and it's a
skewer
it's so many challenges okay let's take
Ricky it
and we take this check yes okay that was
satisfying eight rating points nice so I
have five pending challenges let's pick
a random number
there's Siri give me a random number
between one and five one Google player
first victim okay let me configure
everything
[Music]
and
I
will
this guy is here he is here okay
let's play Sicilian I'll take like
Sicilian variation recommendations
there's any Sicilian players out there
visca thoughts fiscal is great fiscal
was a tournament in Romania that I
played several weeks ago now but it was
nice scenery I didn't do that great
performance wise but everything else
about the event was good am i watching
Pele
I've been glancing at Beale I saw the
results from today but I didn't really
see the games too closely
hello the Fuchs eeeh good to see you
back what time control people can
challenge me to any time control just
anything above like three minutes would
be nice just because of the lag so in
this game I'm gonna play a lion which
I've I like to show slightly lower rated
students because it's just a really easy
variation of the Sicilian and it's
assuming he takes back on d4 with the
night
this guy is saying to me in the chat
finally playing after a long queue last
time good luck okay so he took a long
time to flame they take d4 now I'll play
a night of six
one of the most forcing moves why can't
play e5 because Queen a5 check so Knight
c3 is the best move
and now knight c6 and now we reach kind
of a key position main position I don't
know what we call this opening I just
call it for Knight Sicilian with a
six-night d b5 is the best move and for
my lower rated students I like to show
Bishop b4 because it's just a simplest
move where black wants to play d5 next
and one of the main points is that if
Knight d6 I can play King e7 what's
happening in e7 Knight takes see a truck
takes c8 and white has spent 1 2 3 4 5
moves to trade off his knight for my
Bishop which hasn't moved at all
some knight take c8 I think is the most
likely move here unless he's considering
something else a Bishop g5 but that
hangs a piece right I think he forgot my
bishop could move backwards
I was looking forward to playing that
position with I take CA trip take seats
and he says he says oops except except
he spelled oops wrong as ops maybe he's
nervous
it happens
oh yeah Nathan thanks for sharing the
fisca or thank you night by for sharing
the Fisker playlist the last two
tournaments I played in I made daily
youtube videos with a fellow I am okay
so now I'm up a piece let's not mess up
the Queen b6 here or rip g8
a combination of the two
the start with Richie eight and has a
threat
the castle and then maybe I can get a
king-sized attack
something like Queen c7 or even some
funky maneuver he plays Queen f3 now
this looks like a very juicy move just
gonna play it because this is attacked
this is attacked this is attacked to
lead to more forks the Queen is tied
down to g2 still lights under a lot of
pressure and White's down a piece life
is good
I'm thinking that if he plays queen d3
defending everything
attacking I would like to take take and
then take on g2 but my bishop would be
attacked so he plays green d3 so now it
seems like a good time for Queen b6
bring in another piece
but then he's going to queenside castle
I'll try and be accurate here because
I'm also considering like might take b5
and Bishop f4 preventing queenside
castling
94 was actually not the most impressive
move after Queen D 3
Bishop b5 here
Bishop e5 looks interesting
means like castle we
trade at a six I'm just up a piece okay
I'm not gonna take too long I'm gonna
play the shitty five keep all the
tension and she too is so attacked
Bishop's attacked I kind of figure out
about the chat
do you play Oh Kelly I don't think I've
ever played though Kelly but I would
play it just for the the nature of being
tricky so he plays g3 you also play f4
so I might just trade everything
starting with this
and then I'll have probably have Queen
a5 coming if my take b5 Queen a five if
C 3 a 6
you
and if Knight c3 I just trade everything
you
okay
so now it's a question how do I activate
the bishop
I could play b6
t6
you
let's start with b6 there's a chance
we'll get some initiative on the D file
but I have enough resources to hold
everything together
you
nice
nightbot has a coaster command
I mean look like Queen c5 here
preventing Queen d6 preparing pond d6
someday I'll get my Bishop to a better
square one of these squares
crouton what would you consider the best
beginner opening for whites I mean you
can take a look at the stream title
I might give you an answer but
essentially I like to I like to suggest
two different repertories depending on
the players learning style like assuming
there's a player just starting out
starting our chests and they're trying
to pick an opening I would recommend the
London for players who don't want to
memorize too many lines and just want
some simple setup to play but I would
recommend efore for anyone who is
willing to maybe put in some work and
and basically learn the kind of common
responses to all these defenses like
King's pawn opening Sicilian French
carrot con maybe at some point I'll do a
video series on like opening
recommendations for make newer players I
don't understand King each one
because his pieces don't want to be on
light squares I guess he wants to play
f4 but my bishop has so many targets to
potentially attack Bishop e7 looks
interesting now let's start with a 5
just to be sneaky we'll see if he sees
the threat
send me your wallet
address and I'll send you some Bitcoin
[Music]
is dumb I think he meant streak I was
about to say what is stream laps says
stream labs my Bitcoin address is
actually on my websites if you go to I
am rosen.com slash private - instruction
um and then you scroll all the way down
I mean I can find it's maybe
anyone who's ever sent me Bitcoin
I did buy Bitcoin though I
bought it when it was 20k luckily I only
bought like $14 worth so it was a a good
sized investment for what ended up
happening let's play Bishop a6
when it says r.i.p me and just resigns
that's sad for him
hello to excise sparks
and okay because someone asked I'm gonna
go here and just give people a glamp a
glint a glimpse a glance at my websites
also I'm using Safari because I was
trying to troubleshoot browsers this is
my first time in a long time using
Safari but yeah if you go to my website
you can find oh my gosh I can't even
scroll down zoom in know what is going
on
yeah there's my Bitcoin address uh-huh
anyway let's play some new person uh
we'll get another random number
give me a random number between 1 and 13
it's five five one two three four five
okay molé molé nine six two also do
people hear the thunder because it's
thundering thundering like and the
windows are open actually right before I
started the stream I was doing some like
audio check and then there is a rainbow
but it only lasted very briefly before
let's play c6 I played this once before
the idea is to play a five and just play
positionally on the queenside
and then night a six
and both of us are just
opening principles
it's beginning to rain
you
but this is actually an interesting way
of meeting the Polish I don't think b5
is a good move because I just went up on
and
a few different ways could played b4 I
could play Knight c7 or I could play
Queen b6
you
maybe just night see seven
bring the knight closer to the center
all my move so far have been
- to the left of the sieve our tuba
I don't know what I'm saying all my
moves so far have been on the queenside
I wanted to say to the right of the C
file oh my gosh Thank You Fiona chedda
for the host I did not mean to to
maximize OBS I appreciate that Fiona
I don't think Fiona has hosted me too
often that's nice to see my pawn is
attacked again I could play B for now
no I kind of failed to see Knight c3
will play before now my moves are
continuing to occur on the queenside you
sent a hundred bucks wait I'm so
confused I will verify that in just a
moment
to the side what do i what can I take
the rook or the night as if I take wait
this is interesting I could take here he
takes here I take here you're here and I
have not enough pieces for the Queen so
I have to take on eight am I ever gonna
move anything on the Kings side
if there's any small children watching
please close your eyes starting like a
minute ago
is
game to watch if you want to learn how
to play the opening
so now the pawns attacks I could defend
it with my queen and attack the knight
simultaneously
it's okay I also just failed to consider
a 6v6 would have been a nice move to
essentially doing the same thing though
attacking the knight defending the pawn
that's the correct address
open up
you
you
wait Oh since I've never has been sent
Bitcoin before it doesn't it take a
while for it to like process
wait a minute this isn't be my first
move on the kingside
I really want to play e6 I think I do
though
because as night as is almost trapped I
think yes to move to f4
15 minutes or so interesting and g5 says
Ariel this is casual unfortunately g5
would lose a rook in many cases
I was just calculating Knight f4 g5
Bishop take h8 Queen a1 check but
unfortunately the bishop could move
backwards from corner to corner
I'm probably just gonna start developing
after night f4 so for the young children
you can open your eyes again because
this will be the start of development
and hopefully decent chess chess
principles I could also just play Queen
a 2.82 actually looks more fun attacking
the bishop threatening Queen b1
my knight on a there's actually a good
piece defending these weak squares
actually my queen also defends of the
squares hello - Carm are
Queen B 1 says Nathan Queen B 1 was the
worst move I've ever played but that was
a different position completely in this
sort of position Queen B 1 would be an
amazing move to play
Eric is my
see wallet hot or cold I don't know what
that means does hot or cold me
and it's virtual so I don't know if I
and touch it engage the temperature okay
he's sucking a night's but do I take it
my opponent just said Yolo in the chat
which is a bit concerning
is no fear
and I I have fear against people who
have no fear I guess I'll have to muster
up some courage and just take the night
because it is a free piece he's gonna
okay he's gonna start making threats
I really have to play that age six
oh here's to threats here
don't really want to play nine age six
yes I have to
my nights nights are so bad
I don't know which one's better though
probably okay at least my 911 h6 is
doing something but my night on a8 has
future life plans of moving to a four
with temple and the bishop so he might
ok he's probably gonna take on b7 but
then I can trade stuff yeah he's
probably thinking here because he's
hesitant to take on b7
cuz I'd be happy to trade my bishop
which hasn't done anything this game
Queenie 4 is a move I forgot about
I should have probably
not forgotten about that move
but Kingi it looks okay
for the children who I said could
their eyes a few moments ago you were
supposed to keep your eyes closed
hell for yesterday this reminder that's
been completed
my Kings on d8 thanks Nathan for the
cheer nathan has to go that's so sad
bye Nathan see you in the future okay
92 is a good sign because he's not going
to
destroy me at and now I have time to
maybe actually complete development
debating between 96 and 97 I also have
to move a lot quicker
let's play 97
96
slightly more active and there's some
line where like if he takes take take
okay never mind
weena five here
I just want to Queen shade if he plays
this and I can play this
- did I get ramen yesterday I got ramen
I I got there like as a kitchen was
closing and I knew exactly what I wanted
and they made it for me and it was great
it's the best ramen I've had like ever
okay now I'm realizing Bishop f5 or
Bishop c5 is a queen take g7
it's attacked so let's go back with my
queen
wait no then he can take and still take
on g7
and not lose any material King c7 looks
very suspicious but I'll play its
I'm controlling these squares so he has
no checks
this looks weird so my time is low and
the play Brook g8 it's a slow move but I
just wanted to defend the Jeep on so I
can play this move and now I think it's
under control
know where to move the Queen other than
a five I think or that move but we can
trade trade more
just play you six and then do this
okay let's take
about that it's okay this very weird
game but now it's settling down I have
maintained my peace advantage
equal plans are about to be equal
it was not a ramen place in Milwaukee it
was around in place in Prague it's
delicious
all the food was delicious in Prague his
bishops stuck because it has to defend
back rank and his rook can't defend
because my bishop controls these squares
so this is over and he's about to flag
interesting game mole 962 I didn't read
what he said in the chat but he said
poor children thank you
so just out of curiosity I just want to
see how popular this line is because
it's a playable line the first time I I
saw the line was actually in in Romania
the first round of the fiscal 'pn I was
sitting next to some I am and I am
played against the Polish and he played
this exact line the c6 I think his
opponent played c3 very safe move
my opponent this game okay we'll have to
switch to a chess database
played some novelty actually surprised
Oh
maybe Queen b6 is a move
the 96 looked very logical b5 so just a
new position after you move for okay
let's move on and maybe have a more calm
game
so I check Google today I didn't check
Google but I checked social media and
yeah I I'm aware that like the Google
arts is very much chess related which is
my [ __ ]
watching me play is more entertaining
than Netflix I'll take that as a very
flattering compliment
teddie the ruby first time watching good
to see you can i play the perk maybe if
I'm black I can try let's play
let's get another random number give me
a random number
really
forty-eight is not a number that I can
use give me a random number between one
and thirteen it's eight it's okay
let's count backwards this time 13 12 11
10 9 8 okay rishaad is this just a new
account no it's not
so
this is his first ever blitz game I
guess good luck I'll pre move d6 not
quite a pre move but I'm playing the
perk play Knight of 6 if you just joined
I'm not playing bullets just because I
am experiencing lag and I'm requesting
that people challenge me three minutes
or longer so I hope that's okay
I don't play too many perks I had this
to a few students who played the perk
the main idea that I like to show is the
c6 b5 idea this gaining space on the
queenside there's also some idea if I
ever puts the bishop on c4 to execute
the center fork trick
which could even be playable after
Bishop c4 right away because I think
after Knight 84 there's some line where
this is still very playable for for
black because it's worth it to get the
bishop pair next time can i play h5 h4
if it's a if it's against a London maybe
one confirmation okay I'm checking my
Bitcoin wallets
I'm trying to have my phones connected
oh he moved Bishop III
let's Castle a great thing about the
perk workings Indian are like these
moves are very automatic you can play
them without too much thought but then
at some point you need to start thinking
in this case I'm going to play Knight G
for it because I assume that it's a good
move usually white should play h3
preventing Knight g4 attacks the bishop
prevents Bishop h6 ex Linton wants a
Benoni
my videos are replacing your coach
I mean
the path to getting better at chess
usually requires a bunch of different
types of things so if you have a coach
try and like maximize the value that you
can get from them
even if it's just like iTunes or like
recommendations to resources but it's
good to hear it okay you enjoy the
videos but there's a number of things to
focus on
thanks Karate for the follow I don't
think we had sound the other day I don't
know what has activated the sound I want
to play e5 here also kind of want to
play knight c6 but h3 is coming so I
have to act somewhat quickly i'ma play
knight c6 there's an there's actually an
idea that I learned from Ben Feingold
because I played against him a few years
ago in a tournament and he we went into
some pierce line perk line where I was
white and we had some very similar
situation
which i think is going to happen so I
won't I wanna send you to say anymore
here yeah so this this situation
happened or a fine gold-plate 'if I've
just completes the price I think it's a
strong move counter attacking the bishop
crouton thanks for the follow and the
point is that okay even if black loses a
pawn in some of these complications if
the diagonal opens up and I get the dark
squared Bishop there should be full
compensation and if he plays Bishop g3 I
should be relatively happy now I can
play Knight d4 I don't think he ever
wants to take giving me the half-open
efile but maybe he doesn't want to take
because my knight is is very strong on
d4
you
you
yeah if you have a coach that kicked you
out of the club for not winning first
place maybe find the new coach h3
I'm calculating 906 take-take-take and
then night a key for this is I think
this is actually a thematic it's a croon
Feld idea or Kings Indian idea
only reason why I'm reluctant to play
9:06 is because I also want to play f5
on f3 let's start with this f5 will come
some day Gary Frances things for the
follow
there's a lot of things I want to do in
this position
let's start with 9h v useful improving
move camp TX thanks for the sub with
twitch prime yeah one of the things
which I don't really want to say because
I feel like he might be watching so I'll
just draw arrows and then remove them
quickly is that but it might be hard to
set up also do I have tactics here take
take take
I think this wins a piece
because I just removed the defender
bishop and then we trade queens then the
dust settles and I'll be up a bishop or
I'll take on f1 if he takes on c7
I guess he could win ce7 and then g6 but
also be up a piece
and then I'll have my Bishop h6 move
anton squared me
is this a real anton squared me probably
is
I don't think he's famous and not for
people to to like the imposters using
his name thanks for the follow Anton or
Dan
yeah it's Dan
I think we had this discussion yesterday
if I'm supposed to call him down or
Anton because Fiona calls him Anton so
confusing so this guy allowed Bishop h6
which I kind of wanted to do a few moves
ago to win the Queen but now I'm winning
the exchange also I don't have to take
right away
this is always nice when you pin a piece
but you don't have to take the piece you
just watch them suffer
once he gets out of the pin I'll take
the rook
so many follows keith patrick 5 thanks
for the follow at some point i'm
probably gonna just turn off the follow
notifications because they get a bit
annoying if you're felix thanks for the
follow let's play a 6
it's enjoying enjoying the suffering
from late
I'll probably turn off the follow
once I hit some like magical number
maybe like three thousand my close to
3000 4000 I could take the rook now but
let's play b5
make him decide what PC wants to keep
wait a minute someone
okay what is this question thanks Buster
for the follow so alte a cz is asking am
i confusing things I thought c4 c4 is
not the London c4 is called the English
opening but London is a city in England
so maybe that's why it's confusing also
I'm in London for those of you who
didn't hear or haven't been here since
the beginning Navarre thanks for the
follow
I want to get my Knight to f4 it's
slightly hard to do I could also just
play before and with upon the simple
tactics
yeah London is d4 and Bishop f4 and a
beautiful city
today it was like really humid and then
it just started raining and I had like a
half hour walk to my my friend's place
I was just drenched by the time I got
here soap it said okay I'm gonna take
the pong
I am NOT here for an event I might come
here in a few months for the world
championships if it's actually being
held here she'll Croat thanks for the
follow
but I'm just waiting until they announce
more information about World
Championships before I arrange travel
I'm just here for a few days because it
was convenient to fly through from
basically to fly from Europe to the US
they have some of the best and most
cheap flights
I know people here so it's nice wait a
minute Bishop g2 is coming I Thunder is
getting louder I think I can play Bishop
here and just trap his knights
so he counter-attacks and he wants to
win the pawn
slightly annoying
but if I think I had rook take be for
just a five rook can't stay defending
the Knights was it really loud my mic is
supposed to pick up sound in this
direction the Thunder is in that
direction but yes if it's loud enough
now there is sirens everywhere feel like
Robert Hess
attempting to stream from from a busy
city f-7s attacked
you
okay now I'm up to pieces and he resigns
good game Rashad 2088 okay let's move on
yeah it's gonna probably become more
audible I think the storm is moving this
way too I've 21 pending challenges give
me a random number between 1 and 21
here's what I found on the web for all
of point to 1 pounds challenges give me
a random number between 1 and 21 you did
not understand me give me a random
number between 1 and 22
the answer is 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
Raja Raja ion our good luck I'm still
gonna check my Bitcoin wallets
um because I'm curious if
bitcoin has arrived but no I still have
my very small fraction Rahul Rahul
something that something thanks for the
follow someone asked for a Benoni
earlier and now it's raining I'm
probably gonna close the window if it
starts raining inside well let's try a
benoni
I don't think I've ever played this move
order yesterday I played a 5 in honor of
Feingold now this is I think a genuinely
real Benoni d6 do stuff like this this
is not my wallet address
pretty sure it okay I'll check
a cream of it
oh wait no I
okay I don't want to show this another
thing there's anything sensitive I see
there's a pending thing
like a pending transaction I'm pretty
sure it is my Bitcoin address if you
just sent it it's pending I really
appreciate that chest bone things for
the follow
just don't take the pawn
actually okay let me find a light to
turn on and then I want to tell an
ironic story okay ironic story hello
I might have to go very soon
oh no it's just so rain making noises
the rain is just hitting the ceiling st.
Andrew thanks for the follow
I think the ship g-force a move okay so
I'm at a friend's place my friend isn't
here
my friend had some excursion today so
I'm waiting for my friend to get back
when my friend gets back I just have to
end this dream even if I'm in like the
middle of a game
but my friend is a chess player and my
friend's grandfather trained world
champions or like very like elite
players
and apparently there's like some
variations in the benoni named after my
friend's grandfather and I know it's in
this like efore f4 line but I forget the
exact variation
so I feel like I'm playing the Benoni at
the right place and the right time the
play 96
the thing
especially for a lot of like newer
players it just looks like a bad opening
because White has a huge space advantage
but at a higher level you realize that
there is there's some interesting
resources to counterpunch this bishop
can be very deadly I'm gonna trade off
because I think this is a general rule
and also white because of White Science
Center
there are targets to attack
a bit curious here do I play night
before or do I try and make see for work
I don't think c4 works unless it does
work
I always have to watch out for a five
but
the threat right now
so if I play night before
should be one would be expected
and my knight is just happy
but normally my night would be happier
if I can get gether to see five
so I'm considering moves here like Queen
b6 threatening c4 you've rook c8 maybe
this is one of the problems playing such
a new openings I don't have that like
the deeper intuition for this sort of
position I know the idea is I just just
have to think a bit more
so night before it bishop b1 at some
point I'd like to double up rooks on the
e-file
so maybe then I start with Queen b6 and
I just stay flexible if Bishop e3 I can
take on b2
I think that's okay
okay let's do it
most flexible move has many ideas trying
to tie down the bishop connecting my
rooks to double-up threatening c4
I don't think I can complain
Miyagi thanks for the comments hello to
nikolai pavlov that's an old name
pay for the comments keep moving xx
appreciate that does my friend live in
London yes how is this ironic well I'm
I'm playing so I guess it's ironic for
wait why was it ironic
because I'm at like a friend's place and
I'm playing basically her grandfather's
opening which I almost never play King
each one good move
not losing a piece
okay now I have candidate moves I have
rookie seven idea of work 88
I've rook c8 idea of c4 I have night
before idea of attacking the bishop
probably gonna play one of these moves I
also have Queen B 4 which is interesting
hitting the pawn and preparing c4
I'm drawn to Queen before
I have a feeling this is a typical idea
especially when white commits to a 4 B 4
is just so weak and in this case okay
the main idea is to push c4
and they'd see five
for the follow night hopping pong
grabber that's essentially what I want
to do in this position I want to hop my
knight to c5 and grab the c4 pawn
it's going to take a lot of work though
so might be five was one of the moves I
had on my radar I was thinking I could
just play C for defending and attacking
why not
this is hard for white to attack the
Queen on before
haven't really been focusing on time but
this is a casual rapid game 10 plus 5
my opponent from from India not the best
connection how's my connection my
connections beautiful sealing panda
thanks for the follow
within Rick's here
push the same idea and then push the
pond
I guess that's true
but rook c8 I guess could allow was I
scared of rook c8
maybe it allows Bishop c4
white chess blockades I just assumed my
queen is more active on b4 and I want to
at some point double efflux on the
e-file like maybe right now
see five hangs upon
make sure my Queens not getting
trapped
I don't think it is
it's risky chess sir
you
rook f2 interesting move so he wants to
play Bishop but does he want to play
Bishop d2 Eric mo Ravich mer Ravitz it
whatever your name is thanks for the
follow bishop okay so let's imagine rook
a e8 Bishop d2 Queen take b2 rook b1 oh
but then C choose hanging think rook F 2
does anything
maybe he wants to play rookie too
because he can play rook e1 I also have
Queen e1 here then rook F 1 I know on a
repeats so I'll play rook e8
I like the peace coordination like the
rooks and knights other Knights going to
come in
Bishop is just kind of
kind of doing nothing but it's one of
the best pieces in the benoni anyway
this is just because it exerts so much
pressure
I don't think d6 is hanging currently
but maybe tactically quite could
consider taking and then doing this and
I take here to here to here to here to
here and I went up on or no but I don't
went up on do I win upon ya cuz I would
win the ung pond
Queen c3
I don't think that's a good move because
I can take and now why it has a lot of
problems
because I can take on f2 with check-in
some lines and I'm attacking his queen
too many times a salt egg with check and
then after I take back on b4 I'm hitting
the bishop
I could also throw in ith three if he
plays King G 1 this is just lost
you
sometimes this is what happens you just
build up pressure keep building keep
building keep building and then then
they just collapse but leading up to
that the moment of collapse it still
took work to find the best moves
and special this Bishop is almost
trapped only one safe square so you
could also play 983
just up with rook here if he plays on
I'll probably go for some meeting never
mind
okay eighteen Bishop d2
although mop block to that comment let's
go back to 1818 so before blundering
Bishop t2
in
position so this is what I was thinking
but I could take on b2 attacking these
two things
Brooksie one would probably be forced
Bishop c3 is a move wait a minute die
plunder Bishop d2 okay I would have
thought in this position because I know
I'm realizing taking the ship c3 and now
the Queen is actually trapped I don't
know if I'm I don't think I'm getting
enough for it last night Tiki for works
that taking four could still be
interesting
then he could take and then my queen is
still its attacked twice it's brutal
yeah Bishop d2 is a much better move
then I would probably play queen c5
- III
I don't know who's better here
because if I want to avoid repetition I
have to go back to c8 but that allows
night take t6 when's this fish of d2
I've C 3 C 3 might be playable
I wonder what would have happened if he
played Bishop d2
because I originally I said I'm taking
on p2
I would probably it would hopefully
realize bishops III
I would think consider c3
I do have a suspicion that this might
just be a draw
due to repetition if this is the best
line for both of us
that would be a buzzkill but let's okay
that's my guess let's turn on sock
fishin see starting in this position
oh it might kill that as a computer
so I won't leave stockfish on
two long white is better why oh why can
avoid the repetition Queen before
'if i've
5z 5 5 i can take
protip if you want to play a sock fish
move and you have it turned on just
press spacebar you don't have to
actually use your mouse
some people just get lazy and just hold
down spacebar and then sock visual third
game against itself
Bishop d4 so there's tactics and Bach
has to give some exchange okay
interesting
can I please go back a bit further and
evaluate rooks eh just for toilet noggin
sure
I just really want to see 18 b3 so many
questions 18 b3 also is I usually prefer
in line notation
you
III o threatening Bishop a3
yeah I probably just let my guard down
there's like there's a lot of scariness
I don't think b3 is going to move though
because I can take and then attacking
they're both rooks actually
Bishop III is not trapping the Queen or
is it
if it is shopping the Queen I should win
enough material for it
Bishop a3 I take with check
here to here
hmm
black is doing okay here
I don't know Brooksie it I'm not
forgetting just for toilet noggin
but what move rook c8 before my Queen
month rook c8 here
yeah maybe this is just a better move
cuz white doesn't really want to play
the ship c4
it's in the bishop's just kind of a
nothing piece
again like these positions I don't fully
understand
would continue
now bring the Queen to b4 thanks toilet
noggin though I feel like bringing the
Queen to b4 it just causes Blackmoor
problems and it can cause white problems
so
yeah I don't know maybe I would play
rookie seven queenie eight
and still probably be a fights
maybe night before there's also like
some circumstance where white could just
continue development Bishop here and if
this this well I guess Knight c5 then I
would get my my desired night move
okay I'm gonna move on play another game
let's see
okay there's 18 pending challenges give
me a random number between 1 and 18 it's
18 Wow
so the the most recent person who
challenged me now it's moved up to 19 so
this is 19 all brown is that right yeah
all brown good luck
I don't think I've played all brown yet
I've noticed all brown has challenged me
in many other previous streams so this
is our first time playing good luck I'm
playing on London I don't think I've
played a London today it's my stream
title it's my location X Linton you're
welcome I hope you learn something I
learned something I was an instructive
Tononi game okay let's play Bishop f4
and I'll see what he does mm-hmm okay
continue normally
usually a good sign when they start
thinking I move like two or three
just a very beginning
c 5 c 5 is one of the main lines lacy 3
just a few months ago I was playing
Knight f3 and Knight bTW - before c3 but
recently I found c3 is is interesting
with mighty to hear the idea to me Queen
b6 with Queen b3
usually leads to some slightly better
position for whites
so black has a few ways of playing this
position but I'm not going to tell him
what to do appiy do things for the
follow you six is one of the most main
lines and now we'll go into probably the
most main line
zgr why did you say c5 question mark
Bishop e7 is actually a very interesting
move that I've studied like with some
some strong players because idea is to
play Knight h5 like as early as possible
if white plays Bishop d3 9 h5 is a
strong idea because Bishop g5 would not
be possible so I'm gonna play h3 here
a pocket of safety for the bishop Queen
b6
now earlier I would play Queen b3
here I'm debating between
Queen b3 rook b1
I think I'll still play Queen b3 though
because if the Queen's ever get traded
this this sort of queenless mental game
is very pleasant for whites and one of
the ideas to answer is e jars question
if c4 happens it usually goes in White's
favor I can simply retreat to c2 and
blacks committed the structure and then
II four would be very strong and e4
would be very playable within just a few
moves so he's not doing anything to
relieve the pressure
which is actually an interesting
approach
cuz now if I play Bishop d3 he could
play c4 and I would have to take on b6
maybe is located just gonna start with
Bishop e2 though just making it so c4
can be met with Queen c2
is mike is my screen layout not good
weight jarring is
let me know how to improve the the
street layout because I've oh because
this is showing why is this showing
shouldn't might be showing
Arielle with $5 I can't see your message
because it's blocked by my video now I
can see it sort of instructive
entertainment thanks Ariel
you
let me know if that's better
now how it got changed I'm using Safari
so it's a bit slightly different from
Chrome I mean the castle here
you
Hey okay this did this wasn't like a
donation through stream labs but I do
want to give a shout out to I already
forget the guys name too
so the person who donated a hundred
Bitcoin it has been received I really
appreciate that
that guy T why Inc
did I say a hundred Bitcoin I meant Oh
point zero one two one six six six three
Bitcoin Keith yeah Keith Patrick thank
you so much I don't know if I'll use it
on scotch um but I'll put it to good use
which might just mean holding on to it
until it's worth a lot more
at least until
hopefully until whatever news comes out
of that what is it ETF or something
haven't been following the crypto news
too much
well yeah thanks so much this is
monumental it's like the first ever
crypto donation I received okay so back
to the game Bishop d6 I'm gonna play 95
just such a common London move
because then if he ever takes I would
probably take with pawn and get some
king-sized attack but there's an
additional tactic in this position which
is a bit unusual but I might already be
threatening it and I'm not going to say
anything because it might actually
happen and he might be watching
I did not mean to say 100 Bitcoin when
why do you play h3o I answered that
earlier
I played h3 because he had played Bishop
e7 signifying that night h5 would have
been some idea to trade bishop for
nights
so I played H to me to a lot of Bishop
h2 now I'm actually considering to take
with the bishop I'm not sure
I'm going to take with the pond it's my
first instinct
my tactic has gone away my tactical
threat was before knight c6 and then
Knight c4 I think winning at least a
pawn
if I'm not mistaken because take take it
would have been that would have been
cool but anyway he just hung a nice
that's not as cool but I'll take it
it's having a bishop on each to is
another way to prevent night age five by
trade Knights good trade nights and now
I'll put the rook in the center there's
only one open file in this position so
rook t1 is a no-brainer move I'm also
preventing him from developing his his
bishop and very soon I'll probably just
look to destroy the Kings side and other
ideas rook d4 Bishop take h6 from g4
some sort of meaning attack
it
you
okay there's no need to to take this
position too seriously
I'm gonna play this move because I think
it it's tricky
is to win
more quickly
uh what am I doing in London there's no
tournament in London I'm just here for a
few days because flights are cheaper
back to the u.s. from London and I have
a good friend here and it's just a
beautiful place to have kind of a
weekend getaway
so my plan is working a whole point of
point 84 it was essentially it's a
access e8 and now now I'm threatening me
into
oof
with streaming you have to convince him
to come to leech s and then I'll
challenge him
okay made into that was nice um what did
he do wrong he hung the Knights that's
probably the big thing but there is some
positional idea of this game with this
h3 moving against Bishop e7 now one okay
one sort of opening trick opening hack
that all all tell people in case that
they're looking for something to play
against the London I can recommend this
Bishop e7 line because ok one of the
main lines is Bishop d3 and then Knight
h5 and I think blacks score is decently
here
like if flack just gets a bishop hair
it's uh it's a nice asset going into the
middle game but the fly plays h3 then
black can be very very sly and played
Bishop d6 and basically take advantage
of the fact white has played h3 and this
is a mainline position with h3 included
where white can't play the main move
Bishop to Bishop to g3 because a pawn is
no longer on each to so then white would
have to probably make some concession
probably play a different move here
there would be a few options like Bishop
take d6 here or 95 but I think black
equalizes pretty easily here now in this
game I played h3 knowing that he wasn't
gonna play Bishop d6 unless he's like
really well prepared but okay this is an
interesting trick to know because it's
not too often when you're black that you
can afford to do this like Bishop e7 and
then right away play Bishop d6 am I not
entertained oh that was too excellent
any sound on my PC o z nation chests let
me just say hi to z nation chests in the
chat so he can hear me through words
okay let's play another game I have 13
pending challenges and another follow
Johnny thanks for the follow
give me a random number between 1 and 13
it's 6 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
wait a minute someone disappeared 1 2 3
4 5 6
it keeps changing stop it 1 2 3 4 5 6
Sakamoto okay 1367 a good luck
Socko motto from a great country which
I've never been to it's ye5 the scheme
elastic hold was on 6 will need a
slow-motion replay for that it kept
changing and I was slow to count let's
play a petrov russian defense
Chessmaster thanks for the follow
let me read toilet noggins message
toilet loggin yes you can
yeah you can email me or just send me a
message via leech s if you want to email
me and just use my website contact form
um I will say it could take some like
the turnover time could be a week to two
weeks just because life is busy but yeah
I would be happy to take a look
I'm going to take with the D pawn it
plays g3
now okay I'm playing a garbage opening I
should explain this is I think this is
what we call the Stafford gambit which
is just not good but it's very tricky
it's an attempt to win quickly
there's many different traps Allura
thanks for the follow you need it by
September 15th interesting deadline um
yes I can turn off sound notifications
I'm really sorry with conferred the
sound being distracting I'm gonna play
h5 here and go all out for the Kings
I'll attack let me go into stream labs
and try and figure out these sound
settings
stopped raining it's still cloudy but
there's some sunlight looking for
rainbows
very slow
I'm sorry if I'm blocking the board
one moment alert box
and then we please see three
you
so he wants to play d4 he's not hiding
his intentions
and d4 is probably a good plan
so I have just a very simple move Bishop
b6 preventing d4 in the sunset if he
plays it I just take an e4 I keep my
diagonal and clearly clearly with h5 I
want to put an either Bishop to g4
you
yeah this is being very very slow
[Music]
okay there's no longer any sound I'm
saving the settings if someone wants to
follow me and see if the settings have
updated that would be nice
okay I've achieved my g4 should be noted
his bishop is kind of tied down to the
thing the pawn
so he could run into trouble if he takes
the night's and meanwhile I'm attacking
this pawn
so far I like the UH I'm liking the vibe
from this opening just like some
constant initiative
Phoenix wants to learn the Scotch gambit
needs to learn the Scotch gambits
it tried to play the Scotch gambit next
game toilet noggin with the follow and
there's no sound okay
success
parla noggin wasn't following thanks for
the follow toilet noggin I'm gonna play
Queen H or
I think that's a very strong move
strong move after calculate
I think it's a strong move
you
you
on the surface it looks just crushing
because I'm attacking stuff left and
right but this is a key line Knight f3
and now I assume I can take this and
come out okay
because now I'm attacking Queen
of multiple discoveries if he takes I
take back with my queen
oxeye sparks you're welcome
so the whole chat you're welcome I hope
this is now a more pleasant watching
experience
certainly a pleasant playing experience
so I'm up material
I've won the pond ax and I'm just up to
exchange I have some attack I'll play
Bishop g4 ideas of continuing the H pawn
push
so you want me to turn back on the sound
oh free bishop I love to sound on for
subs and shears and donations so if you
want to hear sound you can you can do
one of those things that was pleasant
the 13 moose this is one of the things I
enjoy in chess is finding openings to
quickly beat lower rated players no
offense to lower rated players out there
just finding openings which maybe aren't
objectively best but kind of
caused problems early on and this is
nice we're like black just as a
wide-open center a nice development
king-size attack
can we get another sublevel please or a
way to subscribe for longer what does
that even mean
what are sub levels
I think it's just built into twitch you
can only subscribe on a month-to-month
basis
but maybe I can change it
um you can donate bits by typing cheer
so just type like cheer one and then
that would be like a test chair to cheer
one bit I think that's how it works
there might be another way
what do I think of the nez met TD naav
russell emo attack in sicilian for
whites
thanks for the cheers you jar sound is
still working for Cheers
what is this opening what does this
cheer 10,000 bits Thank You Keith
Patrick that's so generous
and Nathan isn't even here it's just
like start a bit war so you've you've
given $100 in bits and $100 in Bitcoin
something about him drawn to the who's
drawn to the bits a bit currency thanks
so much
I do appreciate it and now I'm just
distracted I lost I lost my train of
thought I think I was trying to answer a
question
[Music]
oh the Russell emo variation whoever
asked that if you want to elaborate like
what move what move order like II for
see five things are the sub Keith of so
generous and he's not even drunk yet Wow
quick who asked that
year toyline noggin
take of cheering Oh for the sake of salt
okay Flipboard we're going back
you
I prefer bits or Bitcoin
asked me after August like asked me
after the like the etf news or is
announced and then I'll tell you
yeah I don't know
both are very nice bits are nice because
like everyone like is astounded but okay
before ETF was rejected
I've come to learn to not believe I
think anything that people say about
like major news events so someone was
asking about this with Bishop b5 was it
really rejected yesterday well I prefer
bits
okay I'm looking for my
for the one person who was asking about
this but I don't see him I don't think
he's been following up the Teddy the
Ruby I do coach people if you want to
find out more information you can you
should be able to use a coach command I
will take you to a link you can also
just see my leech s coaching profile or
just my websites but okay let's play
another game fifteen challenges give me
a random number between 1 and 15 it's
fine it's fine so easy
leather pet 10 plus 3 Russell emo is the
same
it's the same as a really mo okay but
what so Russell emo is knight c6 Bishop
b5 writes and then Moscow is Bishop e5
check
okay I'm gonna play the same opening if
he lets me I really like the vibe from
from that last game a13 moving
now he's thinking he probably was
watching he saw the last game now he's
scared to take the pond
I will admit I don't have too much
experience with Russell emo but I know
like it's a very dangerous and
underestimated opening Oh Centre for
trick this is another reason why I like
to play King's pawn opening against the
low rate of players because so many
people walk into this and then it's just
a good position for
[Music]
black
at least equalizing
so White has a couple options here
taking the pawn or treating the bishop
should be 5
you
he's taking his time
okay he takes his fine
back usually people play Knight c3
Elia and Carlos thanks for the follow
okay so there's essentially two main
reasons why Bock is better in this
position I'm pretty sure I said the same
thing like a day or two ago because I
have the same position very recently
reason number one why black is better
the two bishops reason number two a pawn
on e5 just gives more more space more
Center and these two advantages alone
and just make it very pleasant I'm gonna
start with Bishop g4 or Bishop d6
probably Bishop d6 wait now I'm
conflicted
yeah I mean the play Bishop d6 there's
possibility is where if you really wants
you could try and trade this night for
the bishop but then it just helps my
center grow about castle
I'm trying to remember the game I played
the other day because I got some really
quick King side attack
it involved moving the Queen some
interesting square
another attacking idea here is f5 f5 e
for
let's do it
keith patrick with a tier 3 sub didn't
you just sub
first sub was tier 1 tier 3 tier 3 gives
you access to all the emotes which very
few people have access to I think now
you have a an e mode of my face and a GG
emotes thanks Keith
also thank you to my opponent for just
giving me a very nice position
more space initiative
he's counter-attacking but I can play
this that walks into a pin but okay to
think ahead
my plan is to play queen g6 which if he
lets me if it's my move here and I play
queen g6 I think I'm just winning a
piece because the night would be chased
away from defending the bishop
so he has to do something about that
a queen g6 is still gonna be the start
of some larger attack
you
how to say your name a mindfully
welcome to the chats
our kind to you
and thanks for the follow okay let's
play this
as bishops almost trapped to h6
g5
for cahiim I'll start with this
also d-force hanging
is it hanging because he could take on
e4
oh this is just a good position for
black though
pieces are coordinated White's pieces
not so coordinated maybe I could have
taken on D for it but it would have
gotten messy the counter-attack in this
case I'm trapping the bishop I'm also a
threatening mating ideas let's go for
this is how does he defend g2 he could
play g3
but then the position will fall apart I
think g3 is the only way to stop mates
else he wants to play g4
so I could take the pawn or the bishop I
just kind of want to take the pawn so
now I'm threatening double-check
just actually just made into and if he
takes on g3 it's also made into
so this is painful for whites
he is just over six minutes to cry and
suffer
you
I just realized my opponent wish me good
luck I forgot to wish him good luck now
I think it's too late to wish him good
luck
he plays king h1
interesting attempt
I don't see forcemeat yet but it's very
very close
jeetu King takes you to G take F to King
each one
I don't have any checks in the H file
I'm also looking at G to Pithom King G
one
I just want to win quickly I think I'll
just take the pawn because now I'm
threatening made in one like how does he
stop it
chess for newbies asking why not G take
F - well that's the move I played I hope
it's a good move
actually I know it's a good move you
just hope this game ends as quickly as
possible
but he's surviving he's not giving up
backing your rook
now I'm going to take and then put the
Queen line h5 if he takes back with his
queen I'm still threatening force mates
and I don't know how he's gonna defend
now cuz two bishops are too powerful
combined with the Queen and the rook
take my night a few months what line do
I recommend against French defense Wing
gambit
did you ask this other day I think I
know this is a comment the other day and
I just forgot about it I actually have a
whole study on me chess how to play for
black against the wing gambit which I
will try and locate after this game
assuming this game ends quickly
please keep surviving but this is made
into ship G - I can pre move this okay
so I don't think I'll analyze that game
but good game Leto pets
uh yeah there's another classic classic
opening trick okay so for for this guy
I'll elbow a bowl cause I don't want to
hurt myself pronouncing your name but I
go to study and then we're going to type
in French defense wing autocorrect
gambits
my study
oh wait no I need wing gambits
this one I made the study many months
ago after someone just randomly messaged
me asking what's playing in something
gambit and then I was curious so this is
for blacks perspective I have some
analysis here everything saved if people
want to you can actually if everyone
knows this but if you want to like add
your own analysis you can go down here
and you see this oh my gosh you should
click the clone button and then you can
basically make it your own
what is going on there you go
the Safari is a weird browser anyway
well I recommend against wing gambit is
d4 which maybe isn't the most intuitive
move but it's a movement Alessa let me
copy this did X I sparks beat me to
share no he beat me to sharing the link
I'm sharing it anyway so just click the
link that I shared or that X I sparks
shared and take a look your take a look
yourself and let me know if you have any
questions ok another game
do another game let me see
maybe I'll do another game
I might just be biased this time and
just pick someone who I want to play
you
okay we're gonna play the highest rated
player who's challenging me to three
minutes which is the sky good luck
because I'm hungry
and it's been a long day of traveling
for me too so uh we'll end it here
one more game also Keith Patrick if you
want to play as keep a strict
challenging me I would play Keith
Patrick just because he's so generous
[Music]
okay I'm playing some Italian I don't
know if I intended to play but we have
some what is this here we have some
variation
disengages assume this should be
equalizing somehow for black let's start
with castling and then Bishop g4
black should play f6 maybe now
like all the pieces have purposes in the
position but Queen b3 looks scary maybe
I can take both nights and then take on
e5 and then take on e3 I'm just trading
everything we're gonna go into some
endgame I could take on f3
it's a free pond but d5 is going to be
weak
but I have 97 in many cases like if rook
D 197 could also just take the bishop in
Queen g5 check let's do that
okay that's a little bit scary wait this
is really weird
mmm this is really weird I was
calculating Queen g5 King eh one night a
five but then he has rook d8 double
check mates so I have to be slightly
careful
and be Queenie no I have to I have to
play Queen g5 probably Queen g5 keynotes
okay interesting position
really
my bishop but now I think things are
settling in my favor
as I'm still up upon this king is weak
my rooks coming to a fete
I don't think that can be a good move
move
I don't know I'm thinking here I'm gonna
play Queenie for I was debating between
Queenie for a night take e5 but now I
can take on e5 threatening night a3 with
Chuck
I have to be careful King f2 I can't
move my knight cousin he mates me
oh okay let's be very careful me Queen
here
what am i threatening I just blunder
I just blundered
that was embarrassing I don't know what
just happened there and there's no
increment and I'm below a minute and
he's above two minutes
I'm gonna try and bail out with a draw I
have no idea what I just did there oh I
can take the bishop with check I'm
winning again okay now I have to win in
enough time 33 seconds all I need to do
is trade Queens it's easier said than
done
yes okay now it should be easy when
plenty of time Nathan is back just in
time for the end of the stream
Nathan missed so much done generosity
I wonder if Nathan just went away to
like secretly disguise as other generous
people
welcome back Nathan how did I hang a
piece sir ago
I just got careless I forgot he could
take the rook and take the knight so I
should have I should have played Queen
h4 such a simple move attacking the rook
and the king okay this is probably a
good time to end before any disasters
happen um just go Keith Patrick doesn't
want a game he's 1100 it's not too
terrible
maybe according to Ben Feingold though
but everything's terrible according to
Ben Feingold speaking of Ben Feingold is
he still streaming let's wait let me
check for my phone easiest
if Feingold is streaming yes he is okay
let me just say goodbye everyone goodbye
to the chat thanks guys for watching and
donating and cheering and following and
subscribing an especially Keith Patrick
five thanks for the bits and the Bitcoin
we're gonna raid what's been Feingold's
username on Twitch I want as many people
as possible to join the raid uh so on
the count of three raid benjamin
feingold hopefully this works goodbye